going to see the elephant is a story
about a young man who believes himself
to be the greatest writer in the history
of the world the only problem is he
hasn't written anything yet it's a it's
a condition many young writers find
themselves in he moves to San Francisco
because he thinks of this as a romantic
literary city and a place for him to
fulfill his destiny and he gets a job
sort of sweet talks himself into a job
at a place called the morning trumpet
which is a third-rate newspaper whose
you know hey day was probably in 1850
right after the gold rush and it's been
going downhill ever since even still
they think Slater Brown the name of this
young man is something wrong about it he
just doesn't quite add up and so to get
rid of him they say if you're such a hot
writer go find us a story and they're
pretty sure they'll never see him again
he proceeds to go out into the city of
San Francisco to look for us story and a
series of things happen to him and in
very short order he's the most powerful
person in the city and that's that's the
nuts and bolts of it but when I said
people ask me how I got came to this
idea and I was walking around San
Francisco one day about seven years ago
and I saw this guy I saw my character in
a coffee shop and that was the impetus
for me to start to tell this story and
the same character is in dallas today
he's in New Orleans he's in New York
City he's in London it's the romantic
idealized young man or woman who has
been a passionate reader and wants to be
a writer and now is on the process of
figuring out how to get there and that's
really what the books theme is about on
some level
I don't think I'm probably a good judge
of my themes yet I think they're still
emerging and I don't think when I sit
down to write I'm usually drawn in by
something that I've heard whether it's a
piece of dialogue or maybe I've seen
something and that's sort of the
starting point when i started to write
this book going to see the elephant I
didn't know where the end was which was
a huge mistake and I also didn't know if
I could do it I mean it's sort of like
training for a marathon you believe you
can do it you want to do it but can you
do it and this book was a process of me
figuring out how to do that and writing
it was a huge leap of faith for me but
also you know as I said earlier perhaps
a benign mental illness I feel like
themes are things that are found after
the fact and that most writers don't
consciously engage in that or if they do
I think sometimes the work suffers
because of that I I find my entry point
into these things to be more around
characters or a particular feeling or
mood and not you know I want to write a
you know a story about coming of age or
something like that
you